jump into this next story from Forbes
alleged Paul Pelosi attacker pleads not
guilty to State charges David de Pape
the man accused of blindly attacking
Paul Pelosi Nancy's husband
pleaded not guilty Tuesday to attempted
murder and other state charges according
to several reports as authorities allege
to papay specifically targeted the
pelosis and aimed to hold the house
Speaker hostage
uh I'm just going to pause and I don't
believe any of it I don't know what to
believe there's a lot of really crazy
stories I don't believe the the the gay
orgy story I think that's a little too
extreme maybe the people are like
speculating as to why he was there but
the narrative keeps changing for
whatever reason the police are the media
reports are changing too rapidly on this
one for me to understand at all what
happened so here we have a story of some
weird goings-on that's about I don't
know what do you guys think what do you
think happened why don't they just
release the security footage so we can
all just know what happened because I
didn't they come out saying that there
was no security footage because I
actually went back I found from 2020
there was an article article that came
out uh early January their their house
had been attacked and they're like
security footage was yeah you know on
there and and they don't release it now
and they said they reported the police
had body camera footage I'm hearing a
bunch of crazy stuff that an unknown
person opens the door then they said
actually that's not true then they said
when they came in they saw Pelosi and de
Pape fighting over a hammer now some
people are reporting that Pelosi himself
opened the door then they said he was in
his underwear now they're saying he
wasn't in his underwear like like what's
how do you remember that up yeah yeah
how do you mess that up it's like the
bin Laden raid he was wearing long like
long johns is that what they're called
is that what they're doing well we
didn't mean underwear we meant long
johns tidy whities anywhere from the
1930s
with the butt flapping yes when when
Paul called the cops he mentioned David
by name is this this is what I've heard
yes so he knew the guy so if he knows
this guy and then that guy has knew that
he was Nancy's husband I'm thinking this
is my story that I've got in my head
Paul's got some dealer Paul's a crazy
dude wild man you know much love Paul
whatever I don't care I'm not going to
judge you on that so you got this guy
coming over your house at two in the
morning
he knows that it's Nancy Pelosi's
husband so he's stewing this Paul guy or
this uh David guy stewing with his
Stoner friends and they're doing all
sorts of drugs out in the East you know
I know these people from La like I I
lived with these people they get crazy
you Ian no do dirty hippies go can go
crazy from psychosis too much we they do
a lot of drugs and Other Drugs
um and so they're like this guy very
well may have issues with Nancy Pelosi
he's like I'm gonna do it tonight's the
night and he goes over there and he gets
all freakish and like but I think that
they knew each other I think that he
would and then they're gonna they're
gonna throw this guy under the bus
they're gonna try and throw this guy on
the bus for terrorism charges when it
turns out like Paul was probably like
he's probably Paul's dealer or or some
kind of like relation to Paul Paul knew
his name you don't just get rare you
don't know random attackers names when
they come into your house yeah well so
so we have updates from Politico here's
what they say five new details Paul
Pelosi told police he woke up with the
attacker in the room the speaker's
husband was asleep in his bedroom When
de Pape broke in through a glass door
entered and to speak to Nancy Pelosi
according to the affidavit no security
was present at the time I I got to ask
why that is I mean this is this is
Pelosi Paul was wearing a pajama shirt
and boxers and the attacker arrived
Jenkins said he appeared surprised to
see the men in his room according to a
police account based on an interview
with the papay this is why you have guns
and why we believe in the Second
Amendment because
um you you wake up in this strange man
in your room with you know threatening
you and you're armed you have a lot less
to worry about
San Francisco police officers found
supplies in a backpack the Bape carried
zip ties tape rope a pair of rubber and
cloth gloves a journal and at least one
hammer with him to the pelosium so there
were two hammers according to the
affidavit law enforcement also seized a
sword and two hammers in the garage
where the Pape lived interesting so this
is a uh this is almost like the
Kavanaugh story except the Kavanaugh guy
got apprehended yep debate told police
he was like the country's Founders after
Paul Pelosi informed him the speaker was
at Home Depot said he would sit and wait
for several days for her to arrive the
affidavit said and when Pelosi tried to
use a phone housed in an in-home
elevator to call the police de Papa
blocked him an in-home elevator oh I'm
impressed not surprised though de Pape
also did not leave after plus he called
9-1-1 because he felt that much like the
American founding fathers of the British
he was fighting against tyranny without
the option of surrender according to
Papa's statement to San Francisco police
alleged threat to break her kneecaps de
Papa told police intended to take the
speaker hostage talk to her and break
her kneecaps if she lied this dudes are
nuts
the puppy said in a police statement he
wanted to lure someone else he wanted to
use Nancy to lure another individual
they have David said the document
doesn't say who the other other
individual might have been but Bobby
told police in the same statement that
he viewed Pelosi as the leader of the
pack of Lies told by the Democratic
party it's really weird that a guy can
live in a house with a black lives
matter sign in the window a pride flag
this house rejects hate sign and then
all of a sudden just be a you know
Auntie he could be a manga guy how about
this many of these leftists also hate
Nancy Pelosi it's really that simple I'm
not buying there wasn't any security
yeah I don't think anyone is yeah how is
that possible that Pelosi would have no
security it's crazy they have dudes that
hang out in front of their house like
all day I mean you you pointed this out
we have security and we're not third in
line or right anywhere near government
or you know one of the richest people in
the world mysteriously under of course
very lucky circumstances that the
Pelosi's are under yeah but but this is
an attack again that the media is using
as its galvanizing push for more online
censorship for the destruction of speech
and with Elon Musk just buying Twitter
this is the topic that a lot of people
are discussing and the corporate media
is running the narratives information
conspiracy theories bad people having
free speech bad because it leads to
these situations that happen with uh
Paul Pelosi and that's disingenuous and
it's absolutely you know has no
credibility to it when you actually look
at the facts of the situation here well
Roscoe read up a good point in super
chats he said maybe the same CCT company
that did the prison Epstein was in did
the Pelosi resonance or and probably I
think it was the same company that did
the Pentagon surveillance uh on on 911
as well that had all the security
cameras everywhere oh that's a great bit
yeah on the security company for the
intelligence agencies and it's like yeah
yeah exactly you guaranteed to shut down
during an emergency they have like a
button they can press that just like
creates an error you can automatically
crash your system with the Press of a
button and it looks like a total
breakdown or or they can be like
actually serious like we're the best
security and then this happened to
accidentally you know fail all the time
at critical moments just when you need
the most to fail well they'll be there
for you they're saying there's body
camera footage of this yeah Tucker
Carlson asked for it they said no yeah
just put it out yeah then
I'm actually on board with this as long
as they have the evidence and they're
not releasing it I am going to just have
to believe then it was a gay orgy yeah
that's right three guys that's so much
more fun isn't it well so look there was
a third guy according to police report
they're changing their report yeah but
but look
if if you're refusing to release the
evidence showing us what really happened
right well then I'm gonna assume the
worst I'm gonna assume Paul Pelosi was
look I don't know the gay orgy thing I
think he's trying to buy drugs I really
do that that is likely that night it
could have been David just going over
and he's like David what the hell what
are you doing here at 2 A.M and David's
like I want to talk to Nancy's tweaking
out of his mind and Paul get out of here
maybe but no security no he had a third
guy open the door the cops don't just
say that on accident if that was the
report there's a third guy a third
person then there was a third person
then who opened someone went and asked
them to change the report the third
right right security at guard who knows
yup yup because this isn't maybe
security guard maybe and then they were
like well then how did this guy break in
if there's a security they let him in
because they know him probably exactly
the guy's local in the area knew him
here's what I think dude's probably a
dealer because they said that he like
they say that you know I don't know I
heard the dudes a druggie or something
Paul Pelosi calls him up he comes over
and he's like you got the stuff yes and
then David says it's it's it costs I'll
tell you what happened David goes it's
50 bucks now and Paul goes 50 bucks it
was 35 yes and he was inflation what do
you expect and he's like I'm not
spending 50 bucks I came all the way
down here giving my 50 bucks I have
stocks to buy they got getting into it
and they're fighting security guards
like what's going on then he's like I'm
gonna call the police unless you get out
of here I'm done with you and he's like
call him see if I care do it I dare you
and then he calls him and he's like yeah
there's a strange guy in my house and
then a fight breaks out third guy's like
I don't know what's going on no no I
don't know about that I'm I'm mostly
kidding but you make a good point Ian
you don't accidentally say a third
person open the door yeah that makes no
sense right that was very intentionally
that there's a third person there that's
what the cops said honestly this idea
that this far leftist dude had a radical
transformation into a q Anon Maga guy
come on that's crazy well you know I was
thinking about that because there's that
famous clip of uh Pelosi she's talking
about smear campaigns and how you just
put out the wrong story up front so by
the time the truth comes out nobody
cares anymore and so that's what I think
this is is they're just put out the
smear campaign for their own political
purposes it doesn't matter clearly but I
can't I just I find it really hard to
believe that this this reminds me of
like the craziness of the Alec Baldwin
story because we talked a lot about how
the the scenario for Alec Baldwin to
have accidentally killed that woman is
like winning the lottery three times in
a row like accidentally doesn't check
the gun after Decades of of training on
set accidentally it's loaded with live
ammo he accidentally points it at her
accidentally pulls the hammer back
accidentally pulls the trigger like come
on like all of those things you know
it's possible I guess but the simple
story is actually just he pointed it and
shot it like why didn't he check that so
I look at this story and I'm like okay
you want me to believe
that if far leftist who lives in a house
with a BLM with a BLM sign a pride flag
a hippie leftist with stickers on the
bus in their parking space that has a
bunch of leftists like pro pro liberal
Democrat stuff in San Francisco in
Berkeley or it was San Francisco was it
Berkeley that's interesting I think he
lived in Berkeley and then this happened
in San Francisco at Paul's house right
right right right so I'm supposed to
believe this guy all of a sudden just
had his radical transformation to a
trump supporter even though he's a
Canadian illegal immigrant he has this
radical transformation
knows where the Pelosi's live shows up
there's no security is able to get in I
gotta believe all of those things for
the story to be true so yeah then I
gotta believe the police accidentally
said there's a third person they gotta
then I gotta believe they accidentally
report he was in his underwear are you
kidding me after all of those accidental
reportings I don't believe it I'm sorry
I want to know who didn't know what
happened who he wants to talk to like he
was like Nancy's gonna be honest with me
or else I'll you know the threaten about
her kneecaps but like honest about what
what's going on here that sounds
personal sounds like they know each
other and then who's this other person
that he wants Nancy to like corroborate
something for another person like it
just sounds all like personal family
drama yeah it was pull up maybe it was
Pelosi's son's dealer maybe maybe it was
their son's dealer and he showed up
because he was like dude owes me money
security guard let him in because they
know him and then he went to he went to
Paul and said your son owes me money
you're gonna pay me no I'm not I don't
care what my son's doing and then he is
like apparently his son was there you
want to check this real quick wow and he
he's probably like I'll go to the media
I'll tell everyone your son's doing a
bunch of drugs you don't want this kind
of information and then you know the
Pelosi's are like there's one way to
stop this story from going out there get
the hammer out yeah
get the double a batteries in there
immediately
he may have been there after the fact
but look I'll just say this if you want
me to believe a whole bunch of crazy
circumstances to believe your insane
story like that's conspiracy theory
territory dude a conspiracy that far
leftist hippie guy is radicalized then
then it bypasses security what did he do
was he like was he like uh you know
yippee Kaye climbing through the air
vents Die Hard style got inside the
building this is ridiculous
I think it's you know you know it's
plausible
son owes him money for drugs
he shows up the house security guard
says hey man how's it going lets him in
Junior's not there goes to the dad hey
you owe me money Paul your kid's not
paying me you're paying me he's like get
on my house I'm not paying you anything
then he's like if you don't leave I'm
gonna call the cops and that's how it
happens then the third guy opens the
doors security guy was like leave me out
of it then they're like how do we
explain this to the press that there was
a drug deal gone wrong or something I
don't buy the official story it doesn't
make it doesn't make sense isn't that
funny that the stories we keep getting
are all like this we all have to talk
about it and figure out the nooks and
crannies of it ourselves without just
getting the story like the Alec Baldwin
story too yeah like every single time
every week every day there's a new story
and we're like well here's here's like
uh 10 of the story but we're not going
to say this is this is important right
here because someone's super chatted
Cosmic Cosmic surgeon said I've sold a
lot of drugs but never in my underwear
dude wasn't even in his underwear
apparently that's what I'm saying and he
had a backpack
so I don't I don't I don't buy the story
man guy gets radicalized the cops get
the story completely wrong I I just
looked at him and I assumed that blue
jeans and a t-shirt was underwear whoops
the third guy actually same guy if there
was no third guy who opened the door for
you it was uh Paul Pelosi but he was
fighting with the guy with a hammer yes
so he's fighting with the guy with the
hammer makes his way they both wiggle
over the door he opens it for you as
he's fighting this is insane come on
I'll tell you this I get it we don't
know what happened how about you you
release the surveillance footage in the
body camera footage and then we'll all
know exactly what happened the story can
go away exactly
I don't see how you could prosecute this
story without body camera footage at
this point we don't use footage anymore
for these stories though I really never
footage ever so Dave is the kind of
things he's uh he said he's innocent so
he's he's going declared innocent sorry
he's pleading innocent I wonder what his
side of the story well he's released
that statement so that's the other thing
too it's like he told police these
things okay sure I'm definitely down to
look and I want to hear him say it the
challenge just when the police have
already gotten all this stuff wrong
expect me to believe them the cops are
like he was in his underwear and a third
third dude opened the door oops never
mind and now you expect me to trust you
when you say here's what he told me yeah
the crazy guy said this last night I was
thinking I can't wait to hear David's
side of the story and then I got this
like message from God I got this impulse
of like there's no way we're letting him
talk to the public and that was from
Paul Paul's like there's no way we're
letting David talk to the public right
now what if they Epstein like what do
you mean that you're letting him this is
all just like in my in my imagination
but I'm like is this the kind of energy
like is this real are they like in
control are they in cahoots with the
cops I don't see why they wouldn't be
the speaker of the houses family local
police like I think they probably know
each other pretty well yeah first and
foremost no matter what I find it hard
to believe there was no security there
yeah just insane apparently that the
Pelosi's have safe house security is the
company that is Pelosi's private
security well there's also a
neighborhood security company too based
on that story that I found from 2020
there's a there's a company that goes
around for the neighborhood itself then
there's the Pelosi security then they
also have security cameras so there's no
reason
then they also have Capital police
officers that fly from Washington DC to
literally watch them at their home which
has been targeted politically before so
so it's just absolutely mind-boggling
they have no security come on thanks for
checking out this segment from the
timcast IRL podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
Monday through Friday at 8 pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the timcast IRL podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
Monday through Friday at 8pm and we'll
see you all there